on September 16th protests broke out in
Tehran and quickly spread over the death
of a 22 year old maksa amini
eyewitnesses saw her beaten to death by
the morality police this is a heavy
topic puts a really important topic what
can you explain what happened the
protests are now in their sixth week
the death of that young woman
occurred who was visiting Tehran as a
tourist
sparked
something very deep
that particularly concerned the younger
Generations that is what you would call
the equivalent of the Z generation in
this country yes they call themselves
in person because Iran follows the solar
calendar of its own as an ancient solar
calendar and this the the time that they
were born they were in the
1380s that's what they call themselves
it is hashtag for the 80s
and the well the circumstances that
surrounds the uh
unfortunate death of this young
beautiful uh Kurdish woman
is really tragic she was arrested by the
what is referred to as the morality
police
morality Patrol called guidance
police that is
presumably there were two women fully
clad that is officer is serving on that
force and two men
and nobody exactly knows what had
happened she had been beaten up
and apparently there was no uh uh sign
of any wrongdoing on her side she was
fully covered
uh it seems that
there was some altercation in the
process
and the the outcome was that she was
unconscious
not necessarily when she was arrested
but in the course of the detention when
they take them to a center presumably to
re-educate them yeah and she apparently
collapsed and maybe my sense is that she
must have had some kind of a problem
because of the skull being broken or
something has happened and she died in
the hospital the next day
and that's through the social media
was widely spread throughout
Iran and almost the next day
surprisingly you could see this outburst
of sympathy for her
people are in the streets weeping
because she was seen as such an innocent
young woman 22 years old
and the family the mother and the father
also mourning for her
and being a Kurt visiting Tehran
this all added up to really turn her
into some kind of a martyr of these
cause
and that's what it is and her
picture
graphics that were artistically produced
based on her portrait has now dominates
basically as the symbol of this protest
movement and the protest movement goes
on everybody was thinking or at least
the authorities were thinking that is
going to die out in a matter of a few
days but it became more intense
first in the streets of Tehran by young
women mostly probably between I would
say 17 18 teenagers to 20 to 23 or
thereabouts and then to University
campuses all around the country and then
even to high schools and that also made
it a very remarkable protest movement
because first of all it involves the
youth
and not necessarily the older
Generations you see them around but not
as many
also you see men and women together
young
girls and boys
and um
they are adamant they are desperate in
the sense of the tone of their protest
and they are extremely courageous
because they stand against the security
forces that were immediately
were sent off to the streets so and in
full gear that is so what are the the
currents of pain emotion
um what is this turmoil that Rose to the
surface that resulted in these big
protests what are the different feelings
ideas that came to the surface here that
resulted in such quick scaling of this
protest well if you listen to the uh
main slogan which is the message of this
movement
it's called women
life Freedom Zan zendeji Azadi which is
a translation of actually
the Kurdish equivalent which is close to
Persian being in the European language
and it's apparently initiated uh first
in this Syrian Kurdistan
where they were fighting against the the
Islamic daesh forces uh because they
were attacking the
yazidis there and the women being
enslaved but the message as it moved or
historians are interested in this kind
of Trends so it's just moved to
Kurdistan and from Kurdistan now being
the message of this movement reflects
pretty much uh sums up what this
movement is all about women
in the Forefront because of all the one
might say discriminations the treatment
the humiliation that this younger
generation feels well not only the
younger Generations but most of the
Iranian secular middle classes since
1979 basically
for the for the past 43 years and uh
they would think that
these all basically symbolized or
uh
represented by the varying the mandatory
varying of the hijab which is at the
core of this protest you see the young
women if you look at many of these clips
that comes through in the past six weeks
women in streets take off their
mandatory scarves which is a young child
or some kind of a head covering that's
all and they throw it into the uh
bonfire in the middle of the street and
they dance around it and slogans
so there is a sense of complete
rejection
of what this regime for 42 years 43
years have been imposing on women it s
not as it's sometimes been portrayed a
movement
against hijab through and through but
it's basically says you know there has
to be a choice for those who want to
wear hijab and those who want to remain
without a job yeah the hijab is a symbol
of something much deeper much deeper and
actually before we get into that it's
interesting to note that in many of
these demonstrations we see in the
University campuses or in the streets
you see women with hijab
uh young women with hijab are next to
those have to remove their hijab and
they are together basically protesting
that's the most interesting feature of
this uh of these demonstrations and then
men and women together against the
segregation that the regime has imposed
upon them in all these years now in
terms of what it represents
as I pointed out one is the question of
the whole series of one might say civil
and legal
uh discriminations against women
you are considered as a kind of a second
class citizen
you depend on your men there's a kind of
a
patriarchy that has been
institutionalized in the Islamic
Republic in a very profound fashion
and that means that uh probably
in matters of divorce uh marriage and
divorce
in matters of custody of your children a
matter of inheritance in matter of
freedom of movement you depend on your
husband your father your brother a male
member of your family your child even
your your son
could could be the case and because of
that obviously a younger generation who
is so well informed through social media
knows about the world as much as an
American does American kid does probably
sometimes more they're very very curious
it's from what I hear or sometimes that
I met a few of them outside Iran you'll
see that Hadith this a new generation is
completely different from what the
Islamic Republic wanted to create in its
social engineering it's basically the
failure of 43 years of the Islamic
Republic's acts of imposition of a
certain as so-called Islamic values on
on women then it's a matter of Education
you would see that there is segregation
in the schools
one of the issues that now right now is
at the heart of this demonstration is
that self-services in many of the
campuses of Iranian universities are
segregated male and female to different
rooms to different Halls now they are
breaking through the walls virtually
everywhere and sit together
in order to basically
resist the authorities who wants to
impose segregation in matters of
appearance in the public of course it
may seem to us as a kind of trivial and
secondary but appearance is important
clothing is important how you would
imagine yourself is important they don't
want to be seen in the way that the
authorities would like to impose upon
them as this kind of an idea of a chaste
Islamic woman who is fully covered and
is fully protected the idea of a male
member of the family protects the female
that is what you see at the heart of
this uh rebellion and of course that
goes with everything as the second part
of this message the idea of life
basically means if you like to use the
American equivalent of this pursuit of
the happiness that's what they want they
want fun they want music they want
dancing they want to be free in the
street they want to have girl boyfriends
and live freely and don't be constantly
looked by the big brother to tell them
what to do
and not to do or or not to do so that is
you that they share with you with the
entire
with the entire Iranian society as of
all although the older Generations
that's a big puzzle but you would see
that the older generation don't so far
at least don't take part
as extensively as one might imagine and
this is a variety of reasons perhaps you
can get to that later on if you like but
as far as this younger generation they
don't care they don't listen even as
much to their parents as the older
Generations did so all the or one might
say even the nature of the relationship
between the parents and the youth has
changed it's not the concept of again a
major a patriarchy that a father or even
a mother
who tell the daughter or son what to do
because basically they have to negotiate
it's fundamentally a rejection of the
power of authority parents government
yeah it's that every person can decide
their own fate and there's no uh
lessening of value of the wisdom of old
age and old institutions precisely
that's what it is yeah and
they are surprisingly aware
that where they are as a generation so
it's a sense of a pride as we are
different from the older generation from
your parents to compromised and lived
with the restrictions that the Islamic
regime put on you your grandfather your
their grandparents or the generation
that actually involved in the revolution
of 79
the parents which were the middle
generation
and these are the third generation of
the the revolution of 1979 and therefore
they differentiate themselves in terms
of their identity from the older
generation
so that's the life part of it everyone
can go more and more they want to access
and they see on social media what
happens in the rest of the world they're
well aware there are much better
digitally
skilled than my generation for instance
uh and and they know about all the
personalities they know about all the
celebrities they know about all the
trends that goes at outside Iran so
that's a second part of this message and
then of course the third part is the
word Azadi meaning Freedom or Liberty
which is this long
standing demand of the Iranians I would
say for the whole Century ever since the
Constitutional revolution of 1906 Iran
has witnessed this problem
of uh authorities that usually emerged
at the end of a revolution
to basically impose its own image on the
population and the youth and create
authoritarian regimes of which over the
course of time
I would say that the Islamic Republic is
divorced in the sense that it's
uh its intrusion is not only in the
political sense in the for instance
Banning the freedom of speech you know
meddling with the
elections uh Banning political parties
all kinds of that things which are the
political or civil freedoms but it's
intrusion into the personal life of the
individual
which is the worst kind in a sense as
you would see that there is always that
Authority that basically uh dominates
their life or monitors their life so I I
and they do it in a kind of a very
consistent fashion which makes this idea
of Freedom so important as part of the
message of this new movement
um you would see that in today's Iran
there are no independent political
parties
there is very little
uh probably freedom of the press I
wouldn't say that it's entirely gone but
it's fairly
limited there's enormous amount of
propaganda machine which dominates the
entire uh
uh radio and TV system in Iran it's
completely in the hands of the
government
and of course you would see this variety
of other tools
for trying to indoctrinate
uh
Iranian population across the board so
that's another sign of this kind of a
sense of
uh sense of being a totally left out
you're not belonging to to what's going
on in terms of power empowerment and
disempowerment so that's that's the
situation as far as the idea of a
freedom is concept and there's three
somewhat miraculously and perhaps
unintentionally
and the three parts of this message uh
complements each other because perhaps
for the first time we see that women are
in the Forefront of a of a movement I
hesitate to say Revolution because I'm
not particularly happy with the
religious
revolutions worldwide and in Iran have
always been so miserable in terms of
their outcome that we have to be careful
not to use the word yes the revolution
yeah so that's where where it stands now